.
Vor mehr als 100 Jahren suchten
solche Inserate todesmutige Männer.
Es war das goldene Zeitalter
der Polarexpeditionen.
Der Basler Xavier Mertz bewirbt sich.
Dieser Text
wird für ihn zur Prophezeiung.
Es wird kalt, dunkel,
und Xavier Mertz kehrt nie zurück.
Das ist das letzte Bild von ihm.
Wahrscheinlich der Mann ganz rechts.
Nur einer der drei Männer
wird zurückkehren.
Mertz wurde in der Heimat
schnell vergessen.
Obwohl er der erste Schweizer war,
der seinen Fuss
auf die Antarktis setzte.
* Dumpfe Klänge *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Nicht im Eis, sondern in den Grau-
bündner Bergen treffen wir den Mann,
der Xavier Mertz
dem Vergessen entrissen hat.
Per Zufall
stösst Jost auf der Maur
auf das Tagebuch des jungen Abenteu-
rers und schreibt über ihn ein Buch.
Je länger ich mich
mit ihm beschäftigte,
desto schwerer liess sich diese ...
... Aussichtslosigkeit
der Situation,
in die er am Schluss gerät,
ertragen.
Ich hätte ihn gerne erlöst.
Abgesehen davon habe ich mich so
in diese Geschichte hineinbegeben,
dass ich abends, wenn ich
nach Hause kam, viel zu viel ass
und so ihre
mangelhafte Ernährung, kompensierte.
Das Buch über Xavier Mertz erzählt
auch die Geschichte einer Expedition,
die hierzulande
keine Schlagzeilen machte.
Denn sie ging nicht für die Eroberung
des Südpols an den Start -
was die Welt damals vor dem Ersten
Weltkrieg in Bann hielt -,
sondern Mertz war Mitglied
einer wissenschaftlichen Expedition
der Australier, die die Küste
des Kontinents erforschen wollte.
Es haben sich viele Fotos erhalten:
Mertz, der Skiausbildner,
Mertz, der Bergsteiger
und Eisspezialist,
Mertz, der Hundeführer,
und Mertz, der Patriot.
* Gläserne Klänge *
Die Aurora, das Expeditionsschiff,
das Mertz im Sommer 1911
in London besteigt.
Mertz ist kein Seemann.
Er ist Doktor der Jurisprudenz.
Auf der Überfahrt
von London nach Australien
muss er sich als Matrose
erst beweisen.
"Juli 1911:
Ich habe London Adieu gesagt
und will an verschiedenen Orten der
Antarktis die Schweizerfahne hissen."
"Als in der Themse die Dampfmaschine
der Aurora einsetzt,
merkt man sofort,
dass 48 Schlittenhunde an Deck sind."
"Die Kommandos an Bord
sind kaum zu verstehen."
"Fast kollidieren wir
mit einem anderen Schiff."
"Es ist meine Aufgabe,
mich während der Expedition
um die Hunde zu kümmern,
gemeinsam mit einem Engländer,
Belgrave Ninnis -
ein angenehmer Zeitgenosse."
"Oktober:
Seit dem Kap der Guten Hoffnung
scheint das Meer
ewig weiter toben zu wollen."
"Den einen Moment steht die Aurora
hoch auf dem Kamm der Welle,
dann scheint es, als jage sie
direkt auf den Meeresgrund,
nur um sich gleich wieder
gen Himmel zu richten."
"Seekrank wurde ich
zum Glück noch nicht."
"Darauf habe ich im Stillen
einen Stolz."
"Die Engländer müssen nicht glauben,
dass wir Schweizer
keine Seeleute sein können."
"Auf See braucht es ebenso wie
in den Bergen schwindelfreie Leute."
"Doch den Hunden macht die Überfahrt
schwer zu schaffen."
"Sie werden von Reling
zu Reling geschleudert
und es ist zu feucht an Bord."
"Ninnis meint, sie kriegen zu wenig
zu trinken - Süsswasser ist knapp."
"Zehn der Hunde
sind bereits von Krankheit
und den rauen Umständen an Bord
dahingerafft worden."
"Sehr betrüblich."
"November 1911:
Der Sturm hat nachgelassen."
"Der Kapitän hat uns aufgetragen,
die Aurora zu streichen."
"Das Schiff soll
bei der Ankunft in Hobart
einen tadellosen Eindruck machen."
"Vor uns liegt das Abenteuer."
"Wem Gott eine rechte Gunst erweist,
den schickt er in die weite Welt."
* Erhabene Fanfare *
Er gehe an den Südpol,
sagte Jost auf der Maur jeweils,
wenn er sich
in sein kleines Büro zurückzog,
um die Geschichte
niederzuschreiben.
Doch nun will er
mit eigenen Augen sehen,
wo die Männer
monatelang ausgeharrt haben.
An jenen Ort, an den ich mich
zu versetzen versucht habe,
einen Fuss zu setzen -
das fände ich natürlich ...
Das fände ich grossartig, ja.
Und dann einfach diese Hütte ...
Das fände ich ...
Darauf bin ich neugierig.
Und so beginnt diese Reise
vom antarktisch
fantasierten warmen Büro in Chur
in die wirkliche Antarktis.
Es ist die Reise des tragischen
Helden und seines Biografen,
die etwas vereint: dieselbe Route.
Sie führt von Hobart
im Süden Australiens
via die Insel Macquarie Island
zum antarktischen Kontinent.
Das Ziel der Reise ist Cape Denison,
das Hauptquartier der damaligen Expe-
dition in der sog. Commonwealth Bay.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Die Bucht von Hobart.
Von hier aus ist das Schiff Aurora
im Dezember 1911 ausgelaufen.
Und hier will auch Jost auf der Maur
sein Schiff besteigen.
Nein, das hier hier ist es nicht.
Sondern das hier: ein ehemaliges
russisches Forschungsschiff,
das nach der Überfahrt
von Wladiwostok
gerade im Hafen von Hobart einfährt.
Schwer vorstellbar,
dass wir 26 Tage auf diesem
kleinen Schiff verbringen sollen.
(Frau) Keine Angst?
- Noch keine Angst, nein.
Aber sicher Respekt.
Als ... Binnenländer sowieso.
Der Leiter der damaligen Expedition
war Douglas Mawson.
Seine dramatische Überlebensgeschich-
te kennt in Hobart jedes Kind.
Mawson ist hier ein Nationalheld.
Im Hafen steht denn auch
ein exakter Nachbau der Hütte,
in der die 18 Abenteurer
Stürmen und der Kälte trotzten.
Das Original in der Antarktis ist im
Schnee und Eis konserviert geblieben.
Es ist das Ziel von Josts Reise.
So habe ich es mir immer vorgestellt
aufgrund der Pläne und Fotos.
Und auch die Betten
sind angeschrieben -
wer wo lag. Sehr gut.
Der Abschied in London: er
mit den beiden Damen auf der Aurora.
(Frau) Hatte er
nicht noch ein anderes Foto?
Ja, das Bild der Mutter.
Das Bild der Mutter hatte er dabei.
Hinter dieser Wand
muss Mawsons Schlafkoje sein.
Die musische Seite der Leute
ist durchaus zum Zug gekommen.
And this ...
Ein Grammofon.
* Rauschen *
* Beschwingte Blasmusik erklingt. *
* Gepfiffene Melodie *
Thank you very much. Very good.
"Dezember 1911:
Die Zeitungen berichten täglich
von unserer Equipe."
"Wir sind 23 Australier,
vier Neuseeländer,
drei Briten
und ich, ein Schweizer Exot."
"Immer wieder bekommen wir Besuch
von Einheimischen,
während wir die Aurora beladen
und die Expedition vorbereiten."
"Kohle, Benzin, Petroleum,
reichlich Proviant und Ausrüstung,
sogar lebende Hühner und 60 Schafe."
"Während unser Leiter Vorträge hält,
machen wir die Stadt unsicher."
"Alle reissen sich darum,
uns zu Tennis- und Golfpartien
oder Picknicks einzuladen."
"Man trifft uns aber
v.a. in der Elizabeth Street
bei Erdbeeren mit Sahne."
"Noch nie im Leben habe ich
so viele Erdbeeren gegessen."
"Als die Aurora ausläuft,
herrscht strahlender Sonnenschein."
"Der Pier der Queen's-Werft
ist schwarz vor Menschen."
"Hobart ist stolz,
dass die erste australische
Expedition von hier abfährt."
"Gerade noch rechtzeitig
gebe ich meine letzten Briefe
vor der Abfahrt auf."
Die Akademik Shokalskiy,
die im Hafen von Hobart wartet,
hat keine lebenden Hühner
und auch keine Schafe an Bord.
Dafür nimmt sie 40 Touristen auf.
* Schiffshorn *
Der Traum dieser Menschen ist es,
einmal im Leben
den Fuss an den Ort zu setzen,
an dem die legendäre Expedition
Mawson ihr Hauptlager hatte.
Ob Wind und Eis das zulassen, ist
allerdings alles andere als sicher.
Die Akademik Shokalskiy
ist kein Eisbrecher.
Aber sie kann durch
bis zu 1 m dickes Eis pflügen.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ihre Besatzung ist russisch.
20 Männer und Frauen.
Jost auf der Maur als Schweizer
ist der Exot
unter den vornehmlich
australischen Passagieren.
Der Exot wie damals Xavier Mertz.
3-2-6-7.
Ja.
Ich habe
schon an engeren Orten übernachtet.
Aber nicht
während dreieinhalb Wochen.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Nach den Strapazen des Jetlags folgt
die erste miserable Nacht auf See.
Wie hast du geschlafen?
Schlecht.
Einmal mehr.
Ich habe ca. 3 Std. geschlafen
in drei Portionen.
Zum Glück weiss Jost auf der Maur
noch nicht,
dass das im Lauf der Reise
nicht mehr besser wird.
Auch das erste Frühstück
will gut ausbalanciert sein.
* Leise Gespräche *
Hast du gut geschlafen?
Teilweise. Es ist schwierig.
Für mich auch.
Aber nicht seekrank.
Das Beste ist,
nicht darüber sprechen,
nicht daran denken,
dann passiert es nicht.
Doch das ist erst der Anfang.
3'000 km liegen
zwischen dem australischen
und dem antarktischen Kontinent.
3'000 km durch
die stürmischsten Gewässer der Welt.
Expeditionsleiter Howard Whelan
trifft sich jeden Morgen
mit dem Kapitän.
Aufkommende Stürme sind dabei
das alles beherrschende Thema.
Kann ich die Windgrafiken für morgen
sehen?
Okay.
Igor Kiselev ist seit 18 Jahren
Kapitän auf der Akademik Shokalskiy.
Die beiden haben bereits
mehrere Antarktisexpeditionen
zusammen unternommen.
That's good.
Das ist besser, als wir dachten.
Yes.
- That's good.
Wind von mehr als 60 Knoten,
das ist ein starker Sturm.
Aber das ist kein Problem
für dieses Schiff.
Es ist einfach unangenehm
für die Crew und die Passagiere.
Man schläft und isst schlecht.
Ich habe volles Vertrauen
in Kapitän Igor. Er ist der beste.
Ich habe Glück.
I'm a happy expedition leader.
(Frau) Okay, so ... Ooh!
* Sie lachen. *
Es ist schwierig, so zu filmen.
So, you know the ship very well?
- Yes.
Jost auf der Maur kämpft derweil
nicht nur mit dem Gleichgewicht,
sondern wie sein Landsmann
Xavier Mertz auch mit dem Englisch.
Das ist gut für ...
... alles.
Doch mit Anne Tanner
hat er jemanden gefunden,
der mit Deutsch vertraut ist.
Die ehemalige Lehrerin
fährt schon zum vierten Mal ins Eis.
Kannst du begreifen,
dass Xavier Mertz in der Schweiz
ein unbekannter Mensch ist?
Nein.
Ich machte diese Reise
schon vor zwei Jahren,
gerade weil sie auf den Spuren
einer australischen Expedition
unterwegs war.
Es war so fantastisch,
dass ich es wiederholen wollte.
Wir erreichten die Hütten
damals nicht, es gab zu viel Eis.
Und ich hoffe,
dass wir es dieses Mal schaffen.
Aber auch, wenn es nicht klappt,
lohnt es sich.
Es ist einfach aufregend,
zu versuchen,
an diesen wunderbaren Ort
zu gelangen.
Drei Tage ist die Shokalskiy
auf offener See,
1'500 km.
Endlich kommt wieder Land in Sicht.
Die Passagiere sind aufgeregt.
Sie hoffen, dass das Wellengang
eine Landung mit den Schlauchbooten
erlauben wird.
Macquarie Island ist für sie heute
wie damals für die Expedition Mawson
der einzige Stopp
auf dem Weg zum eisigen Kontinent.
"Macquarie-Island ist nur 30 km lang
und 5 km breit."
"Unmassen an Seeelefanten,
viele Vögel und Pinguine,
all das ist meinem Auge fremd."
"Am Ufer
verrotten zerschellte Schiffe."
"Hier, auf halbem Weg
zwischen Australien und Antarktis,
werden wir
eine Telegrafenstation betreiben."
"Zum ersten Mal wird die drahtlose
Kommunikation aus dem ewigen Eis
mit der Heimat möglich sein."
"Für den Transport
auf eine kleine Anhöhe
errichten wir
eine primitive Seilbahn."
"Bei Windstille verständigen sich
die Telegrafisten pfeifend
mit dem Morsealphabet."
"An Weihnachten
springt der Wind plötzlich um."
"Die Aurora treibt hin und her.
Das Meer ist zu unruhig zum Ankern."
"Wir müssen umgehend aufbrechen."
"Fünf Mann bleiben
bei der Telegrafenanlage zurück."
"Sie werden von uns erst wieder
aus der Antarktis hören."
Kontrollieren Sie bitte
Ihre Schwimmwesten.
Sie müssen eng anliegen.
Das Glück fährt mit:
Am frühen Morgen ist es fast
windstill - eine Seltenheit hier.
* Perlende Klavierklänge *
Irgendwie wirken Pinguine
immer wie vom Schicksal ausgesetzt.
Ein bisschen ...
Sie stehen da
wie Konkurs gegangene Bankiers.
Ja. Ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Macquarie Island ist Weltnaturerbe.
Aber bis vor wenigen Jahren
war hier vieles kaputt.
Denn Macquarie Island war das Reich
der Robben- und Pinguinjäger.
Mit den Jägern
kamen auch Kaninchen und Ratten,
die die natürliche Vegetation
zerstörten.
Nach aufwendigen
Renaturierungsarbeiten
sieht die Insel heute wieder aus
wie vor 100 Jahren.
Die Öfen,
in denen das Tieröl gewonnen wurde,
stehen noch als Mahnmal
der Schlachterei.
Im Sommer
leben hier heute 25 Forscher.
Und eine Handvoll Unbezwingbarer
während des Winters.
Morgen wird es Wind geben.
Thank you.
- Well, we'll manage that.
Die Ankunft
des Geologen Douglas Mawson
war der Beginn von Australiens
Naturforschung an diesem Ort.
War das Mawsons Telegrafhügel?
Ja. Da rauf hat Mawson
die Masten schleppen lassen.
Funktioniert hat die Funkverbindung
in die Antarktis
allerdings nie richtig.
John Hunter.
Jennys und Naomis Grossvater.
Frank Hurley.
Mertz hier.
Ninnis natürlich.
Greg Holland vertritt die Stiftung,
die sich um den Erhalt
der historischen Hütten kümmert.
Auf dem Schiff ist er der Mann
für die Expeditionsgeschichte.
Es gab drei Ärzte,
zwei Soldaten,
Ingenieure, Segler,
einen Meteorologen, einen
Fotografen, eine ehemalige Spionin ―
darüber reden wir später ―,
einen Bauzeichner,
einen nationalen Skichampion: Mertz.
Natürlich weiss Jost
mehr über Mertz als sonst jemand.
Jost ist der Biograf von Mertz.
Mawson wollte kluge, fitte
junge Männer mit Moral.
Wichtig war nicht, was sie wussten,
sondern was sie konnten.
Greg hat die Hütten
auch noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist ein 20 Jahre altes Foto.
Wir haben den Schlüssel.
Wir sind bereit.
Und so fühlt sich denn mancher
auf dieser Reise selber
wie ein Entdecker.
Wir sehen genau dasselbe
wie Mawson und seine Männer.
Wie er das beschreibt:
die Wetter- und Seebedingungen
am Tag, als er aus Hobart ausläuft -
es waren die gleichen Bedingungen
wie für uns.
Tatsächlich dort zu stehen,
mit allem, was wir über ihn gehört
und gelesen haben.
Dort zu stehen, wo er stand.
Das wird sehr stark sein.
"Januar 1912:
Der antarktische Kontinent liegt
versteckt hinter unendlich viel Eis."
"Mama und die Meinen
denken wohl an mich,
sie haben aber keine Ahnung, wie
schön es hier trotz der Kälte ist."
"Gegen Mittag
erreichen wir Festland."
"Expeditionsleiter Mawson
tauft die Bucht Commonwealth Bay."
"Das Ufer
bietet uns eine felsige Fläche."
"Hier entsteht unsere Basisstation:
Cape Denison."
"Der Wind weht kräftig."
"Wir können nur arbeiten, wenn er
ruht. Dann aber ohne Unterlass."
"Zehn Tage lang
löschen wir die Ladung."
"Über 2'000 Kisten, Werkzeug,
Schlitten, Instrumente,
Skier, Kohlebriketts
und Bauteile für die Hütten."
"Am nächsten Morgen
legt die Aurora ab."
"Für mehr wie ein Jahr bleibt jetzt
die Welt in weiter Ferne."
"Ein jeder bekam
richtige Abschiedsgefühle."
* Langgezogene,
eindringliche Klänge *
Passt bitte auf.
Haltet euch gut am Geländer fest,
wenn ihr euch auf dem Schiff bewegt.
Wir werden etwas stärker schwanken
während der nächsten Stunden.
Die wütenden 50er - so nennt man die
Breitengrade in dieser Weltgegend ―
geben sich alle Ehre.
Es sind starke Westwinde,
die die Shokalskiy samt ihren
Passagieren ins Trudeln bringen.
Zur Freude der einen ...
... und zum Leidwesen der anderen.
Das ist die Stunde
der Bordärztin Lesley.
Hello Lisa.
Okay, so have a rest. Do you need
anything else just now?
Sie fühlt sich ein klein wenig
miserabel heute Morgen.
Hallo Beth, wie geht's?
Eher unterdurchschnittlich.
Du kamst zum Frühstück
und verschwandest wieder, oder?
Ich machte den Abgang,
bevor ich dort ankam.
Wie war es denn
in den letzten Tagen?
Eigentlich ziemlich gut. Aber nach
Macquarie Island ging es wieder los.
Ich entschied,
dass ich mich nicht allzu gut fühle.
Hast du etwas genommen?
Ich probierte etwas
mit stimulierenden Mitteln.
Aber dann kamst du
mit deiner magischen Pille.
Ich hoffe, sie ist magisch.
Zitronen-Ingwer Tee.
Manchmal hilft Ingwer.
Schau, dass du genügend trinkst.
Danke.
Es hängt nicht davon ab,
wie stark oder wie fit man ist
oder irgend so was.
Manchmal triffst es die Mannschaft
sogar am schlimmsten.
Ich war schon auf einem Schiff, da
standen noch zwei Leute aufrecht -
ich und ein Passagier -
und alle anderen waren krank.
Es kann allen passieren.
Schau dir Mawson an:
Er war die ganze Zeit seekrank.
Jeder dachte, er sei
ein unnützer Expeditionsleiter.
Auch die besten Entdecker
wurden seekrank.
Ich komm später nochmals vorbei.
All right? Lovely.- Thank you.
Bye then.
Thank you, Beth.
- No worries.
Das war die schlimmste Nacht
dieser Reise.
Der heftigste Sturm.
Und ...
Es erschöpft einen natürlich völlig.
Langsam habe ich ein bisschen genug.
Ja.
"Mai 1912:
Mit dem ersten Blick aus
meiner Koje sehe ich das Barometer,
daneben das Basler Wappen
und mein Thermometer."
"Mollige 4-5 °C
herrschen in unserer Hütte."
"Draussen nur Wind,
Schneetreiben und eisige Kälte:
-30 °C."
"Bei schlechter Witterung verliert
man draussen leicht die Orientierung:
Hodgeman hat der Orkan 20 m
vor der Hütte zu Boden geworfen."
"Kriechend fand er nach 2 Std.
den Weg zurück."
"Wir hatten in der Zwischenzeit
vergeblich nach ihm gesucht."
"Unter unserer Hütte
lagern wir reichlich Pinguinfleisch."
"Mit Curry
ist es durchaus geniessbar."
"Wir verteilen Orden
für zweifelhafte Leistungen am Herd."
"1. August,
Schweizer Nationalfeiertag:
Union Jack und Schweizer Fahne
hängen heute nebeneinander."
"Ich koche meine beliebten
Pinguineier und erzähle von daheim."
"Die Sympathiegefühle
meiner Kameraden sind so warm,
dass ich einen 1. August erlebe
wie noch nie."
"Weiter entfernt vom Vaterlande
war nie ein Schweizer,
doch tiefer konnte keiner empfinden,
wie lieb ihm die Heimat ist."
Jenny und Naomi sind Enkelinnen
des damaligen Expeditionsarztes.
Ich war zu krank,
um Tagebuch zu schreiben.
Wir haben den Seebauch
von John Hunter nicht geerbt.
Das bin ich.
Das ist John Hunter.
Sie zeigen Jost
das Tagebuch ihres Grossvaters,
das sie
kürzlich veröffentlicht haben.
Wie alt warst du da?
Vier.
Meine älteste Erinnerung ist,
dass er einen grossen ausgestopften
Pinguin oben auf dem Büchergestell
sitzen hatte.
Als Kind liebte ich den.
Warum seid ihr
jetzt auf dieser Reise?
Wir wollten schon immer machen.
Unsere Eltern waren 1998 auf dieser
Reise, auf dem gleichen Schiff.
Sie hatten Glück und konnten
in der Commonwealth Bay landen
und die Hütte besuchen.
Hoffentlich können wir
auch so ein Foto machen.
John Hunter schreibt über Mertz.
Sehr gute Dinge.
Wir müssen es suchen.
"Er ist ein feiner, starker Kerl. Er
ist zweifellos der Zäheste von uns."
"Er wird sicher eine
der Schlittenexpeditionen anführen."
"Er und Ninnis betreuen die Hunde
und er legt Hand an,
wo immer er kann."
"Seine Hilfe beim Häuten
ist unbezahlbar."
"Wenn er nach Australien kommt,
bereiten wir ihm eine gute Zeit,
denn er ist ein guter Kamerad.
Hat Mertz Nachkommen in der Schweiz?
Es gibt keine Familie.
Es waren fünf Kinder.
- Yeah.
Aber es war
eine unglückliche Familie.
Der Vater ...
Der Vater war sehr streng.
Drakonisch.
Keiner hatte Kinder.
No.
Der Moment der schlechten Nachricht.
"Wie muss das gewesen sein
für unseren Anführer,
allein zurückzukommen."
"Wir können nur vermuten,
was geschehen ist."
"Entweder sie sind verhungert
oder in eine Spalte gefallen."
"Armer Xavier, armer Ninnis,
zwei bessere Männer gab es nicht."
"Und jetzt sind sie tot."
"Oh, dieses verfluchte Land.
Ich kann nichts mehr sagen."
"Ich war in meinem ganzen Leben
nie so traurig."
Very sad.
- Very hard.
Very hard.
Ein guter Schreiber.
- Ja, sehr.
Very good.
Thank you very much.
- Das ist okay.
Denkt ihr,
wir werden die Hütten sehen?
Oh, wir hoffen es.
Ich möchte das hier besuchen.
Ein sehr besonderer Ort.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es ist der 23. Dezember.
Zwei Tage nach der Sonnenwende
erreicht das Schiff
den 66. Breitengrad,
den Polarkreis.
Ganz dunkel wird es jetzt nicht mehr.
* Leise Gespräche auf Englisch *
(Mann)
Alle bereit für den Polarkreis?
Five, four ...
(Alle) Three, two, one ...
* Jubel *
Nur wenige Menschen haben den
Polarkreis mit dem Schiff überquert.
Das bringt auch eine Verantwortung
mit sich.
Denjenigen Entdeckern gegenüber,
die vor uns waren
und die diese Verantwortung
ernst genommen haben.
Sie traten für den Schutz
dieses Landes und der Tiere ein,
die es besiedeln.
So dass auch zukünftige Generationen
Freude daran haben.
Ich möchte,
dass heute jeder ein Gelöbnis ablegt
und das Zeichen des Pinguins
empfängt.
Hiermit gelobe ich ...
* Alle wiederholen im Chor. *
... mit dem
Empfang des Pinguinzeichens ...
* Sie wiederholen im Chor. *
... jedem klar zu machen ...
... auch denjenigen,
die nicht hören wollen ...
... wie wichtig die Antarktis
und ihr Tierleben ist.
Kommt jetzt nach vorne und
empfangt das Zeichen des Pinguins.
Bei Jost ist einfach.
Bei mir ist auch genug Platz.
To everyone here: cheers.
Congratulations, well done.
* Sanfte, klirrende Klänge *
Das Eis wird nun zusehends dichter.
Der Kapitän
weicht nicht mehr von der Brücke.
Er muss einen Weg finden durch den
Eisgürtel, der vor der Küste liegt.
Die grösste Gefahr: Strömungen,
die das Eis so treiben,
dass sie das Schiff einschliessen
und festsetzen.
Kurz vor dem möglichen Höhepunkt
dieser Reise ...
Die Suche,
dieses Nadelöhr zu finden,
das ist für alle
natürlich sehr spannend.
Das Meer vor der Küste ist offen.
Die Chancen stehen gut.
Cape Denison, die ersehnte Küste,
liegt zum Greifen nah.
Doch dann machen
die rasenden Fallwinde,
die vom Innern des Kontinents
herunterfegen,
dem Unternehmen ein Ende.
130 km/h,
das ist zu viel für eine Landung.
Die Akademik Shokalskiy flüchtet sich
wieder ins offene Gewässer.
Am nächsten Tag kommt sie zurück.
Es ist 6 Uhr morgens. Strahlender
Sonnenschein. Und Weihnachten.
(Frau) Merry Christmas.
(Mann) Merry Christmas.
# And a happy new year.
# We wish you a merry Christmas,
we wish you a merry Christmas,
# we wish you a merry Christmas
and to get to the huts.
Von mir aus könnte man
aufs Frühstück verzichten
und direkt auf die Boote.
Jetzt will ich es packen.
Ich komme mir -
ohne pathetisch klingen zu wollen -
wie ...
... sein einziger Angehöriger vor,
der jetzt hierher kommt,
um ihm die Ehre zu erweisen.
Dieser Tag verspricht nur Gutes.
Und wieder scheint das Ziel
in greifbarer Nähe.
Aber oben auf der Brücke
ist die Stimmung eine andere.
Kapitän Igor gefällt die Sache nicht.
Und dann winkt er ab.
Das Eis reicht im Moment
fast bis zur Küste.
Es bewegt sich auf uns zu
und dieses Gebiet
wird wohl eingeschlossen werden.
Wären wir gestern
in der Commonwealth Bay geblieben,
dann sässen wir jetzt in der Falle.
Das ist nicht die Situation,
auf die wir scharf sind.
Wir kehren jetzt um
und fahren durch das Eis zurück.
Man kann es nicht planen.
Man kann es wirklich nicht planen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ach.
Die Expedition Mawson suchte
damals tagelang nach einem Ort,
wo man sicheres Festland
unter die Füsse bekam.
Nicht, dass man sich
irrtümlicherweise
auf einer riesigen Eisscholle
niederliess.
Aber als ungemütlicher
hätte sich der Ort der Landung
nicht entpuppen können.
Als man Cape Denison angelaufen hat,
hat man gesehen:
"Ah, das ist ein eisfreier Hafen,
ein Naturhafen,
da kann man
relativ einfach anlegen."
Dass man nachher
diese Stürme aushalten musste,
hatte man in dem Moment
nicht wissen können.
Windböen von bis zu 300 km/h.
Das bläst alles weg.
Man kann mit Recht behaupten,
dass das wahrscheinlich
der windigste Ort der Welt ist.
"September 1912:
Mein Freund Ninnis und ich
schaffen es das erste Mal,
die Schlittenhunde einzuspannen."
"Die Fahrt läuft recht flott,
bis wir uns überschlagen."
"Wir trainieren nun täglich
und bringen den Hunden Befehle bei."
"Abends sind wir rechtschaffen müde."
"Mein Liebling unter den Hunden
ist unbestritten Basilisk."
"Er ist aufgeweckt
und mir sehr vertraut."
"Ich dichte ein Lied für ihn,
den "Basilisk Song":
'When the nights are calm and bright,
seal and penguins are my delight.'"
"Die ersten Schlittenexpeditionen
unternehmen wir ohne die Hunde."
"Herbert Murphy, Ninnis und ich
bilden eine Gruppe."
"Die Schweizerfahne
wird am Schlittenmast gehisst."
"Zum ersten Mal flattert
das weisse Kreuz im roten Feld
in den Eisregionen
des antarktischen Kontinents."
"Dann werden wir ohne Vorzeichen
von einem Orkan überfallen."
"2 Std. harren wir
im Schutz des Schlittens aus,
bevor wir es schaffen,
das Zelt zu errichten."
"In der Nacht
nimmt der Wind noch mal zu."
"Der Orkan löscht sogar die Flamme
im Inneren des Zeltes."
"Wir rechnen mit allem ―
auch mit dem Ende."
"Tatsächlich aber lässt der Sturm
in den Morgenstunden nach."
"Erleichtert, aber mit Erfrierungen
machen wir uns auf den Weg zurück
zur Basisstation."
Der Wunsch der Passagiere ist zwar
noch nicht in Erfüllung gegangen,
aber Weihnachten
findet trotzdem statt.
Auf der Shokalskiy lässt man sich
die Stimmung nicht kaputt machen.
* Jubelruf *
Merry Christmas.
* Entspannter Folksong *
# It's no miracle, this time.
# It's just a dollar sign.
# Gimme, gimme, give me that water.
# Pour it on these grapes of mine.
* Stimmengewirr *
Mertz und ich haben beide
ein Sprachproblem beim Englischen.
Wir reden beide nicht so,
wie man sollte.
Aber ...
... er fühlte sich akzeptiert -
ich mich auch in dieser Gesell-
schaft, die geduldig ist mit mir.
Fünf Tage cruist die Shokalskiy
wie vor einem Mauseloch.
Auf dem Bildschirm entsteht
buchstäblich das Bild einer Odyssee
in der Ostantarktis.
Aber durch Winde
und Temperaturschwankungen
können sich die Eisverhältnisse
schnell ändern.
Den Passagieren bleibt nichts
anderes, als zu warten und zu hoffen.
* Leise Gespräche,
Funkmusik im Hintergrund *
"November 1912:
Mawson, Ninnis und ich brechen mit
drei Schlitten und 17 Hunden auf."
"500 km wollen wir
gen Osten vorstossen
und die wichtigsten topografischen
Merkmale kartografieren."
"Die Fahrt geht in richtig neues,
unerforschtes Land,
das noch nie
ein menschliches Auge sah."
"Dezember:
Die Reise ist beschwerlich,
eine Gletscherspalte
folgt der anderen."
"Jede einzelne
verlangt grosse Vorsicht."
"Unter uns kracht es, wenn die
Schneemassen ihr Gewölbe brechen."
"Ein Teil von Ninnis Ladung
geht verloren."
"Beinah das ganze Hundefutter
ist weg."
"Wir müssen
immer wieder Hunde schlachten
und sie an die anderen Tiere
verfüttern."
"Als wir über eine feine,
flache Strecke wandern,
kehre ich mich zu den Kameraden um."
"Da ist Ninnis weg -
sein ganzes Gespann verschwunden."
"Eine Gletscherspalte
hat ihn verschlungen."
"Wir rufen nach ihm, aber nichts ..."
"Nur Totenstille."
"Hilflos stehen wir am Grab
meines besten Freundes
in der ganzen Expedition."
"Wir kehren um."
"Fast alles Essen, Teile des Zeltes,
Pickel und Schaufeln
hat die Spalte
mit Ninnis verschluckt."
"Die Hunde sind schwach.
Einer nach dem anderen verendet."
"Die verbliebenen Zugtiere und auch
wir stillen unseren Hunger an ihnen,
selbst an meinem geliebten Basilisk."
"Das Fleisch schmeckt muffig
und ist zäh."
"Weihnachtsmorgen:
Mawson rechnet noch mit 258 km."
"Die Hälfte der Strecke
ist geschafft."
"Januar 1913, Neujahr:
Licht unglaublich schlecht,
Himmel bewölkt,
deshalb kamen wir nicht weit."
"Das Hundefleisch
scheint mir nicht ganz zu bekommen,
denn gestern ...
war ich etwas ... flau."
Xavier Mertz hat eine
emotionale Bindung zu den Hunden,
und er muss sie umbringen, er muss
sie schlachten. Das ist das eine.
Und er hat seinen Freund verloren,
Ninnis.
Das ist sein Nachteil
gegenüber dem Expeditionsleiter.
Und ich glaube,
die mentale Erschöpfung -
er, der sportlich so stark
und allen überlegen ist -
führt bei Xavier Mertz
letztlich zum Tod.
* Langsame, sanfte Klänge *
Die Zeit läuft ab.
Der Shokalskiy
bleibt noch ein letzter Versuch,
die Küste der Antarktis zu erreichen.
Spannung baut sich auf.
Wie geht es dir dabei?
Total aufgekratzt.
Das Leben
kann nicht besser werden.
Thank you.
* Der Kapitän spricht russisch. *
Wir sind runtergefahren,
so weit wir konnten.
Wir müssen mit den Bedingungen
klarkommen, die wir vorfinden.
Wir können nicht
in dieses Packeis vorstossen,
es ist zu dicht.
* Sanfte, nachdenkliche Klänge *
So nahe.
Du kannst die Natur nicht schlagen.
Es ist unwirklich schön jetzt.
Jetzt sind wir etwa 40 km
von Cape Denison entfernt.
Aber wir waren einmal 500 m
davon entfernt. Und mussten fliehen.
Ich bedauere es schon.
Ich bedauere es.
Im Dialekt
nennt man das "Lehrblätz".
Man kommt nicht überall hin,
wo man möchte.
Zuallererst kommt die Sicherheit.
Alle Passagiere und die Crew
müssen zurück nach Hause.
Und in dieser Gegend,
wenn wir im Eis stecken bleiben:
Wer hilft?
Es gibt kein anderes Schiff.
* Rufe *
Enttäuschung in Ehren.
Aber irgendwie müssen die Lebens-
geister ja auch wiederbelebt werden.
Douglas Mawson überlebt. Vielleicht
auch dank des Todes von Xavier Mertz.
Denn nun hat er mehr zu essen.
Kriechend erreicht er einen Monat
später die Basisstation. Zu spät.
Er verpasst die Aurora,
die zurückgekommen war und gewartet
hatte, um wenige Stunden.
Mawson muss nochmals
auf Cape Denison überwintern.
Zurück in Australien aber
erfährt er heldenhafte Verehrung.
Er reist nach Basel und übergibt
Mertz' Eltern Tagebuch und Fotos.
Doch Mertz gerät in Vergessenheit.
Es gibt den Mertz-Gletscher
und den Ninnis-Gletscher,
zwei Riesengletscher.
Die erinnern noch an die beiden.
Immerhin.
In der Antarktis
lässt sich nichts erzwingen.
Und beschleunigen
lässt sich hier auch nichts.
Nochmals vergehen zehn Tage, bis die
Shokalskiy wieder Festland erreicht.
Nochmals zehn Tage,
die immer wieder beglücken,
aber auch immer wieder
erdauert werden müssen.
Eine Reise geht zu Ende,
grandios und strapaziös,
die, ohne das Ziel zu erreichen,
ihren unerwarteten Sinn
trotzdem findet.
Besonders schön war es,
zu erfahren,
dass Mertz in dieser australischen
Gesellschaft ein Gedächtnis hat.
Und dass ich mit Mertz
nicht mehr allein bin.
Das ist für mich eine Erleichterung.
Ich komme erleichtert nach Hause.
Ausserdem habe ich 5 kg abgenommen.
Das sind ungefähr die Kilos,
die ich mir während des Schreibens
angegessen hatte, weil ich
mit Mertz litt und für ihn ass.
Ich hatte zugenommen und zugenommen,
bis das Buch fertig war,
und jetzt bin ich
die Pfunde wieder los.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020